la russie et la turquie représente
rethel une menace pour la france dans
ses relations avec le continent africain
c'est en tout cas ce qui semble
ressortir de l'entretien que le chef de
l'état français a accordé cette semaine
au magazine jeune afrique
une interview dans laquelle emmanuel
macron plaide pour l'établissement d'une
relation équitable entre la france et
l'afrique en dénonçant la stratégie
menée par la russie et la turquie pour
alimenter un sentiment anti français
il ya une stratégie à l'oeuvre menées
parfois par des dirigeants africains
mais surtout par des puissances
étrangères comme la russie ou la turquie
qui joue sur le ressentiment
postcoloniale il ne faut pas être naïf
beaucoup de ceux qui donnent de la voix
qui font des vidéos qui sont présents
dans les médias francophones sont
stipendiés par la russie ou la turquie
sans plus d'informations ni d'exemple
locataire de l'élysée accuse moscou et
ankara de financer des intervenants au
discours anti bleu blanc rouge des
intervenants payer voire corrompus si
l'on s'en réfère à la définition du mot
et stipendiés utilisée par le président
de la république
dans une autre interview donnée au
magazine en ligne le grand continent il
part à cette fois ci je cite de
mécanismes de contournement pour
encercler la russie et la turquie
une double intervention qui ne devrait
pas améliorer les relations entre paris
et moscou qui sont loin d'être au beau
fixe depuis quelques temps déjà et c'est
même pire pour la turquie dont les
relations avec paris se creuse un peu
plus chaque jour notamment sur les
questions de la syrie de la libye de la
méditerranée orientale ou encore plus
récemment sur la polémique concernant
les caricatures de charlie hebdo
ce n'est pas la première fois que le
gouvernement français émet des retenues
contre des puissances rivales telles que
la russie ou encore la turquie en
septembre 2018 un rapport présenté au
ministère français des armées est
consacrée aux manipulations de
l'information s'inquiétait déjà de voir
s'imposer sur le territoire africain
d'autres vision que celle de la france
les travaux d'une équipe de recherche
françaises ont révélé une propagation
croissante des contenus russe à travers
le web africains francophones plusieurs
signaux indiquent que l'afrique pourrait
être le prochain terrain de jeu de la
guerre informationnelle
un point de vue pas souvent partagés de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée les
africains estiment que les russes auront
un regard plus objectif sur leur
continent car il n'y a pas de
contentieux politique
la meilleure façon d'avoir des
informations crédibles et d'avoir
plusieurs sources le continent africain
a parlé de plus en plus comme un nouvel
eldorado où toutes les grandes
puissances de ce monde souhaite placer
leurs pions un continent cher à la
france qui est bien décidé à protéger
ses intérêts et quitte à renforcer sa
présence et son influence ces dernières
années sur le continent
emmanuel macron insisté lors de cette
interview à jeune afrique sur la
relation équitable est le véritable
partenariat entre l'hexagone et
l'afrique avec la levée de ce qu'il
appelle des tabous mémorielle
économiques culturels entrepreneuriaux
il cite ainsi la restitution d'oeuvres
du patrimoine africain à plusieurs pays
comme le sénégal le bénin où madagascar
ou encore la fin du franc cfa
je pense qu entre la france et l'afrique
se doit être une histoire d'amour nous
ne devons pas être prisonnier de notre
passé quoi qu'il en soit le chef de
l'état est bien décidé à poursuivre son
opération séduction en afrique
l'objectif pour lui protéger coûte que
coûte les intérêts tricolores à l'heure
où le continent africain n'a jamais été
aussi convoité après le nigeria
l'ethiopie ou encore le kenya emmanuel
macron devrait prochainement se rendre
en afrique du sud et en angola en vue du
sommet france afrique prévu en juillet
prochain à montpellier